[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
may the fourth be with you
it's hump day
[Music]
matt gets
thinks he knows a thing or two about
i'm dating women
venmo me and matt gatz are trending now
which is not surprising it's not
surprising that matt gatts and venmo me
are both trending at the same time is
anyone surprised by this i'm not
surprised by this this is like being
surprised that a bunch of trump-pumping
[ __ ] idiots want to take away liberty
away from women in this country duh we
could told you that
that if you elected a [ __ ] grabber
that he would put supreme court justices
that would strip away the rights and
liberty of women of course
of course that would happen
of course
that's why it's so important that we
stay fast
and we keep our eye on the ball
we do not let up
on these anti-woman
anti-choice anti-liberty anti-freedom
trump pumpers
in this country the minority they are
not the majority
they are the minority ideology in this
country no one gives two shits about
what another person does with their body
most people in this country don't give a
[ __ ] who you love
they don't care what
what gender you want to identify as they
don't give a [ __ ] they just want the
government and you trump hump and idiots
to leave them their kids their kids
education and their their [ __ ]
privacy the [ __ ] alone
we're gonna play howard stern howard
stern says it best he [ __ ] dunks on
the supreme court
he dumps on these trump-humping idiots
he dumps on the electoral college
very important stuff
that we keep this narrative up
we should not forget this we cannot
forget about this we can't let this just
go by the wayside that's why they keep
distracting you with all the leak the
leak we must investigate the leak well
shut the [ __ ] up you don't have you
don't have the majority in either house
of congress so good luck with your
stupid [ __ ] investigation good luck
elections have consequences you dumb
[ __ ] and the consequences we
now have a decision that is going to
strip away the liberty of women in this
country
and don't think they're not gonna come
after you once they're done with women
because they're not done with women yet
next is women's contraception
that's the next [ __ ] thing on the
list and then their vote and then
they'll come after men's contraception
they'll do it
mark my words they want to marry your
children in tennessee
and missouri they want to ban math in
florida
they don't want education matt gatt says
this morning that people are over
educated
you're overeducated that's like being
too nice
what
there's no there's no such thing as over
educating you dumb [ __ ] oh my
god you know way more than what the rest
of the country knows
way [ __ ] more holy [ __ ]
we just can't have people being educated
in this country we need to ban math we
need to make sure these people can't
read
god damn can you imagine what would
happen if these people could do math and
they could [ __ ] read we'd really be
in trouble that's how it feels what is
coming from the fascists from the
republicans
they want to do away with public
education they want to take away your
kids education folks and they want to
take away your consent of your children
even
doubt me they're taking away consent
from parents who have trans children
they're taking away their consent in
these states
that's the state's rights and that's
what this whole [ __ ] decision is
about in the first place it has nothing
to do with roe v wade or pro-lifers or
abortion it's about the state taking
your [ __ ] rights away from you and if
it's real easy to take women's rights
away apparently on the right oh that's
real [ __ ] easy they'll stand back
just watch it happen
not us
not the country i don't believe this is
even close to the majority of opinion in
this country
poll after poll after poll shows
that there's barely even 30 percent
support of overturning roe v wade in red
states the cheeto dust confederacy
think about it
we have a confederacy in our country and
the confederacy doesn't even want to
overturn roe v wade
because the secret is folks people who
claim to be pro-life they get abortions
they use medical services that are
considered abortions because it's
life-saving medical procedures
they use contraceptions
like iuds
and the birth control pill and plan b
you dumb [ __ ] that's why people
will stand up say yeah pro-life i'm
pro-life i think abortion's wrong
but god damn if i had to get one
[ __ ] if i had to get one i might change
my mind
it isn't [ __ ] rocket science
it isn't
and i believe the reason why they're so
focused on the leak is because they're
terrified of the giant that they have
awakened here
we seen last night in in l.a
the lapd roughs up a bunch of pro-choice
protesters peaceful protesters
gazpacho
as marjorie taylor greene would call him
the fascists are out in full force men
beating pro-choice protesters with clubs
yeah okay that's a really good image
for the fascist oh that's [ __ ]
perfect
that's [ __ ] oh that
beautiful imagery there
jesus christ we got a lot of stuff to
get to today um we got a lot of video um
to watch uh we're gonna watch the howard
stern we're gonna listen to howard stern
and destroy destroy these trump humping
idiots
these [ __ ] pro-lifers who want to
take away women's
liberty and their freedom they want the
states to to get rid of contraception
interracial marriage gay marriage
they're after it folks they're knocking
on the door doubt me you better [ __ ]
get engaged you better go [ __ ] vote
you better make sure that you use your
weapon the ballot
as the weapon to save our democracy that
is it that's your weapon the ballot and
not just not just going and marking the
ballot you got to register people to
vote you got to donate to the campaigns
that [ __ ] matter we seen last night
jd vance
wins the nomination for republican the
republican nomination in the ohio senate
race and tim ryan wins the democratic
ticket
so we have tim ryan versus jd vance i
bet jd mandel is [ __ ] pissed at this
point i don't know where jd mandela is
at maybe we'll get him on the show today
i'm just saying maybe we'll get jd
mandel on the show to give his take of
of the ohio race
it really is something
jd vance stomps
stomps
the [ __ ] out of his opponents
it's clear
the thing is i think the numbers bear
out that over 70 of the voters in that
race
voted against jd vance voted against
trump
oh that is not good especially when you
see this tim ryan uh campaign video
folks when you see this tim ryan
campaign video you're never going to
believe this this this campaign video
that tim ryan puts out democrats need to
learn a [ __ ] lesson here tim ryan is
going gonna win that race in ohio
just just buy this hat alone if he keeps
this messaging with this ad
jd vance is completely [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] capital f uck
[ __ ]
in ohio tim ryan can slam dunk that seat
but we have to support him
we have to we have to keep at it we have
to keep our eye on the ball we have to
keep moving forward are these fascists
are gonna take control and they're gonna
take more liberty that is their goal
jesus christ the state of missouri is
trying to pass a bill
that makes it a felony for a woman to
leave the state of missouri and go to
illinois to receive a medical procedure
a felony
i'm going to show you a video today
where there where
the party leaders and i think we watched
it yesterday even their party leader
nick fuentes who who basically who
basically invites marjorie taylor green
to his nazi rallies and she comes and
speaks at his nazi rallies she loves
nick fuentes until she's questioned and
then she can't recall of course she
can't recall [ __ ] anything when she's
questioned but she loves nick fuentes
paul gosar loves nick fuentes
i mean he's the america first nazi
himself
says that women
women
should receive a thousand years in
prison for receiving a medical procedure
that may save their life that's what he
said
that's what he says that's what he says
we have all these right-wingers cheering
that roe v wade is going to be struck
down and women are going to lose their
liberty in this country
that's where we're at this morning
that's where we're at
so may the fourth be with you and let's
go out and kick some [ __ ] fascist ass
that's all i gotta say let's kick their
ass at the ballot box welcome welcome
welcome to the show everyone you guys
know
you guys know that we broadcast every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
right here on youtube twitter and twitch
and now from the midas touch facebook
page
if you're on facebook there don't forget
to click the link at the top of the post
that's our youtube page go subscribe so
you do not miss a thing you don't miss a
clip you don't miss an episode they're
all right here on youtube to re-watch
and why while you're skipping around
platforms you might as well go over to
twitter and follow us at tony michael's
pod tomorrow we will be releasing the
bonehead of the week poll
where you get to vote and you get to
choose who is the bonehead of the week
and then on friday in the second hour of
the show because we do two hours every
single day for all you new listeners out
there
on friday in the second hour of the show
we break down your vote for bonehead of
the week me and my co-host gabe sanchez
go through your decision of who you
wanted to be the bonehead of the week
and we go through the poll
so make sure to like subscribe
and follow us everywhere let's do some
good mornings for everybody chris our
local hate watchers here good morning
chris robin's here jay is here skip is
here mj good morning
david is here kimberly's here oh my gosh
steven's here let's go through facebook
stacey from facebook is here crystal
victor uh who else we got from
facebook uh janie is here cindy is here
mike is here from facebook laura anita
eric is here good morning good morning
jim from facebook christy is here stacy
is here back to youtube kitkats here
amanda is here
holy moly kathy is here deborah is here
holy smokes
you folks just show up every single day
and we enjoy having you here
remember you can get if you go over to
to youtube and get in the chat and do a
super chat or super sticker if you're
not aware what that is just ask the
people there in the super in the super
chat
on the huge tubes the tubes of you
and they'll describe it and explain it
to you how the how the super chat works
if you want to help support the podcast
we have a lot of new listeners from
facebook here today i want to remind
everyone over on facebook we are
broadcasting from the midas touch
facebook page but we broadcast also from
youtube twitter twitch so go follow us
on youtube the channel link is right up
at the top of the post
go click that link
and subscribe so you don't miss a thing
here at the tony michael's podcast
welcome welcome welcome everyone we have
a lot of stuff to get to today i think
i'm gonna have a uh
a special interview here today at some
point i probably at the bottom of the
hour i would imagine and then
after the special interview that we have
uh gabe gabe sanchez will uh be joining
us my co-host and executive producer
uh will be joining us so we'll we'll be
we'll be looking into that
talking about those things did you guys
see that dave chappelle got will smith
did you guys see some of this video
we're gonna watch some of that um you
know that this and apparently
i don't have you seen the pictures of
the guy who decided he would go on stage
and and try to tackle it looks like he
tries to tackle dave chabelle in the
video it's it's
the video is kind of short and it's not
clear maybe we'll watch some of it here
but this is more of this will smith
chris rack stuff where people are going
up on stage look you may disagree with
dave chappelle you may disagree with the
comedian
whatever you want to do don't do not go
up on stage do not go up on stage and do
what they're doing don't do not do not
do that don't think it's okay to go up
on stage and assault someone that's not
cool and this guy learned the hard way
uh you're gonna see
you're gonna see that if i if we if we
get
if we get some video here up on the
screen of this guy you'll see
this is security force basically turned
him into a goddamn pretzel
turns him into a [ __ ] pretzel i mean
literally this guy's this guy looks like
a pretzel on the gurney if this is the
guy if that's the actual video i i don't
i don't know
i mean i am just assuming people are
circulating around twitter i'm assuming
that that's it but if that is the truth
holy [ __ ] they turned him into a pretzel
it's crazy now we're also going to get
the mad gats you guys know i love the
drag matt gatz
a lot of people say his name is matt
gates it's not gates it's not spelled
gates it's gets and here's the thing
here's the reason why you intentionally
say his name wrong [ __ ] that guy number
one
number two
if matt gatz if you're listening out
there if or if he does listen let me
tell you something
this [ __ ] when he hears me say
his name wrong will be [ __ ] pissed so
that's why i say his name wrong every
single time matt getz
apparently matt gatz and venmo me are
both trending so is lying gop
ah it's perfect it's perfect
matt gatz who want he doesn't want
people to be educated
is trending with venmo me and lying gop
absolutely beautiful
peter thiel is trending as well i'm not
sure why i i didn't click into the peter
thiel
uh
thread on twitter
but i'm sure i'm sure it's a doozy you
guys maybe know peter thiel he's the
reason why we have a lot of these
[ __ ] fascists
in our government in the first place
he's funded him back them that piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] that un-american piece of
[ __ ]
when you got the money
you can do whatever you want in this
country right right
we haven't we haven't heard a lot from
elon here lately the owner of twitter
the pretending owner of twitter maybe
we'll maybe we'll find something on that
store today pfizer is also in the news
i'm not sure it's probably
another booster or something i i i
didn't go into the pfizer thread but
maybe we will we will get into the visor
pfizer excuse me thread also the united
states supreme court is trending you
guys know
that we had the draft decision
of overturning roe v wade from these
fascist paid for
supreme court justices
and let me tell you something
folks
they have awakened a sleeping giant
and i believe that this country is going
to mobilize there is no better leaders
in this world and in history of this
world than women
and they are not going to
they are not going to stand for this
[ __ ]
they're going to march for this [ __ ] you
sons of [ __ ]
and they're going after you
they're going come after you
and howard stern puts it best
that this minority rule [ __ ] i mean he
doesn't say this in so many words but
i've been saying this for over a year
this minority rule [ __ ] where that
minority is going to rule over us
that is why our country seems divided
folks we are not divided 50 50.
that is all [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's all [ __ ] [ __ ] that were
divided up 50 50. in 2016 donald trump
lost by 3 million votes he still became
the president but he lost by 3 million
votes and 2020 lost by 8 million votes
we are not divided up 50 50. that is all
[ __ ] horseshit
and if we turn out to vote in this
midterm and we turn out to vote in 2024
we will show the world that this country
is not a 50 50 divide that half of us
aren't fascist
that it's minority rule that is
preventing us from being the country
that the majority here wants us to be
and until we pluck our own heads out of
our own [ __ ] asses and realize that
the enemy is not other [ __ ]
pro-democracy people here
in this point in history our enemy is
not people who do or do not want
to cancel student debt or how they want
to or how they want to do health care or
what they want to do with health care
that's not the enemy
those are the people that we can
actually negotiate with on policy the
people who who believe in making sure
that their student debt relief in this
country those are the people who need to
be in government so they can figure out
a way to help americans with their
student debt but we cannot do that
until all of the people who disagree on
how to cancel student debt on how to
give student debt relief get in a
[ __ ] coalition and push back on these
god damn fascists that
that is the way to
to student debt relief folks
we are on the same team
we may not agree on everything but we
are on the same [ __ ] team we are on
team democracy because that's your
choice in the next four elections
probably
i'm not just going to say this next one
because this next one's important but
the one after that is going to be the
most important the election that is in
front of you as long as we have this
threat of fascism in our country to take
over and to become an autocracy the next
election is always the most important
one every [ __ ] one of them until we
can beat back on this authoritarianism
and we can make sure that the majority
get to set policy in this country for
the majority and the minority just have
to [ __ ] live with it that is how
democracy [ __ ] works not everyone
gets what they want at any given time
they do not
they won't democracy isn't perfect that
is the whole [ __ ] point
why do you think they want autocracy
they want to talk or see because
autocracy is easy oh the the magic man
with the magic wand can fix all of our
problems in an instant
he can build a wall and he can get rid
of this enemy and get rid of that enemy
he can get rid of the brown people here
and get rid of this religion here and
get rid of the women's here and get one
of the women here
and get rid of lgbt here and here and
here
that is autocracy perfection is not what
we strive for
to progress we have to work together
they do not want to work with us folks
fascists don't want to work to cancel
student debt fascists do not want to
work to make sure that you don't go
broke over a medical bill fascists do
not want to work to help
preserve your [ __ ] liberty and your
[ __ ] freedom and your [ __ ] rights
they don't want it they don't want any
of that
that is diametrically opposed to their
[ __ ] core ideology
the good news is
that they are the minority
they are the minority
now they have certain ways that they
gerrymandered and you know a lot of
people will throw that kind of [ __ ] out
oh well they gerrymandered this they
jerry me under that they they have the
electoral college and they can take over
this and take over that and they own
this governor's race in this state and
this legislator
that's because we let them folks
we let them it is a [ __ ]
constitutional republic
our democracy is a constitutional
republic we get to elect our
representatives
we get to work to make sure what our
government looks like for the policies
that we the majority want
and yes in certain parts of the country
they're still going to be the majority
that's going to happen that's how
democracy works
but we do not have to let them
do this [ __ ] stupid-ass states rights
[ __ ] civil war we love slavery type
[ __ ] on your rights and your liberty and
your freedom
this cheeto dust confederacy [ __ ] where
they want certain states to bang up your
[ __ ] liberties well guess what folks
we don't just live in
states we live in the united states
and the federal government
by our decree and our vote
is supposed to protect our rights and
they should yes i know the supreme court
is bought and paid for and it's a very
fascist supreme court but guess what the
only way to fix it
is to get people who will and want to
fix it that is it that want to set
policy to fix it regardless if they do
it in one year i'm tired of hearing that
[ __ ] too well they didn't do this fast
enough they didn't get this done they
didn't get that done
joe mentioned this christian cinema that
guess what if you go out and vote and
you get 53 54 senators in the united
states senate kirsten cinnamon joe
manchin don't make a hill of beans worth
a [ __ ] difference [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them kill that filibuster you want
to kill the filibuster go [ __ ] vote
donate
campaign
talk to your community members
talk to your church members talk to the
people at the pta the [ __ ]
checking your groceries out in the
goddamn grocery line
ask them
did you hear republicans in florida want
to ban math that's a good start there's
you a
pointed question
there's your start to the conversation
if you want to have it
i don't know is that a good rant was
that was that okay i don't know i think
i think i think i think i did a pretty
good job there um we have we have
someone joining us here i'm not sure um
it looks like gabe but it could be
someone else uh is this is this jd
mandel or is this gabe no no jd jd said
he would come later oh jay oh okay jd is
coming later okay i i didn't know he
said jd or have you no no no yeah he
he'll be on a little bit later uh yeah
i'm working with these people to he's a
little busy right now he's doing a host
post uh
vote kind of election uh kind of
follow-up so he's doing he's doing a
little bit of a press circuit right now
so we'll get him on a second i got you i
got you i got you well welcome co-host
gabe at sanchez yeah
everyone welcome gabe sanchez to the
show our co-host and executive producer
well
that rant got me hot man i'm i'm still
[ __ ] pissed and i think we should all
stay [ __ ] pissed um and i think this
energy could carry on into the midterm
and it could really make sure that we
engage people but i do want to ask you
gabe um did you see some of the videos
uh from the lapd i know you're out in
los angeles yeah did you see some of
this video where they were clubbing uh
uh peaceful protesters who were
protesting this decision to to yeah
uh
i saw i saw some of it last night i had
friends who were downtown who are
protesting um and then i saw some of the
videos that were that came out this
morning of cops who were
you know from from the start of a moment
to the finish of a moment of a person
running away and actually getting out of
a cops kind of like
you know clenches right um
yeah it's pretty brutal uh i'm you know
lap so you had some friends so you had
some friends that went down to the
protest because yeah it was protest
during the day and it kind of continued
after dark right and that's and i guess
homeland security showed up because i
don't know were they near a federal
building is that why is that why i don't
know the exact location of where they
were i just know that uh there's a
there's a few videos of what i saw
happen which is like there were people
that were there a few cop cars rolled up
um and then the next thing i see is like
first-hand encounter of someone who's
watching
you know an anti-uh abortion or rather a
pro-right pro-choice um
uh protester
get tackled and nearly miss
my god dude i like my heart almost like
stopped because like they nearly hit the
fire hydrant which would have been
terrible
but they got tackled on the ground they
had they were you know the the two
police officers that were there were
were uh swarmed by other protesters
trying to get them to get off
of this person because there was you
know in in the grand scheme of things
like this person did nothing wrong that
they weren't attacking the police right
they had people that were on the outside
that were kind of
instigating and coming after them but at
the end of the day like this was one of
those things where it's like a little
bit of an excessive force don't you
think right like lapd is also notorious
for the same ways
that uh nypd is like there there is an
excessive amount of force and brutality
that is put on people that doesn't
necessarily deserve it well and that's
because they are a huge police war so
they have a lot of bodies you know right
a lot of police forces around the
country don't have the type of uh don't
have as many bodies as nypd and lapd so
they're really able to rough up uh
protesters here here is um let me well
if i can add it here let's see this this
i don't know if this is the video that
you're you're this is one of the videos
this is
a different angle but this is one of
them yeah um this is a pretty long video
so i want to see if i can fast forward
here and and this is where they're it
looks like they're surrounding a cop car
here yeah this is near the end so there
are these two cops that tackle this one
guy who eventually got out so is that is
that what causes this uh them these
these problems this is them you know
pursuing yeah they are they are crowding
the car and this is before yep and then
this is when they come in
uh so here with full riot gear i'm not
gonna play the sound much
[Music]
so i'm not going to play the sound here
because it is kind of loud so we can
talk over it but you see uh man these
cops look terrified like they look
terrified you know everyone says that
these anti are these uh these these uh
pro-choice uh pro-women
uh pro-liberty protesters these peaceful
protesters are some kind of snowflake
millennial kind of [ __ ] like matt gatz
was saying this morning but these cops
really do look as terrified of
snowflakes i mean they i'm just saying
they look absolutely terrified of these
snowflakes they uh
they look underprepared uh over
militarized and in complete disarray
like they're they're all like
you know they're supposed to be experts
right they're supposed to be handle all
the stress like well i mean let's face
it that's the real that's the real
problem here don't you think is that is
that the cops the cops even though they
claim to be professionals their training
is the problem right right no totally
yeah yeah the training and i mean not to
mention there's we've got a lot of other
problems in la uh
you know lapd sheriff's departments that
run by goddamn gangs out here uh right
right which is insane but
um
yeah in this situation this is what you
were showing in the beginning is when
they're getting pushed away then you've
got the
so he gets pushed off right boom
nearly misses
the fire hydrant almost got him in the
face now he got this cop who's just
wailing the baton on people anyone who
comes near this guy's getting thrashed
around someone's trying to help him
uh they get him again
there's other cops they love the billy
clubs don't they they right lapd loves
the billy clubs and then if you watch
he's like okay okay you know again like
i get it right he feels threatened uh
and i'm glad he didn't pull out a gun
right because that will only make the
situation way worse
but i mean i mean that that's what i
mean about training is they're
escalating this situation like right
like
there was no indication i mean let's
back it up that you know they're
standing outside the cop car right like
right
you know maybe this person got mouthy
with the cop but you're allowed to be
mouthy with a cup right like that that
is your guys
you can call them anything you want
there is no [ __ ] law that says that
you can't get mouthy with a cop that's
[ __ ] i mean you know they can they
can they can arrest you for for you know
uh obstruction or they can arrest you
for you know um not complying and [ __ ]
like that and they can detain you but
there is nothing there's no law anywhere
that says you can't get maui with him
which i'm sure that's what this this
this protester did he's got mouthy and
he got pissed off and he can't control
his feelings you know this [ __ ]
snowflake cop
and he and as a result gets made a fool
of with his partner here
because they obviously know that there's
way more of them than there are way more
of the protesters there are them right
in this situation i mean it's a complete
power move right like it's you know i've
got family in chicago who are you know
work for the fire department or for the
police force like i know um you know
obviously not all cops are bad but there
is a culture within
um law enforcement not to say that we're
gonna you know i think somebody
mentioned um
uh
the
stand for prison experiment that's a
good example of how
one's power and role
can
totally shift one's behavior and
mentality right like you have a group of
students who one of the prisoners and
one are the prison guards and the power
that's i mean like you saw the same [ __ ]
that happened they were the stuff that
happened in guantanamo bay right those
videos that got released of how they
treated
um people that were there that was
prisoners right it's that mentality and
it does breed a very toxic dangerous
culture and if there are no checks and
balances in them then you're gonna
people who go
out like just insane right they will
they will take it out on anyone who
questions the authority or the power
it's a complete ego trip there is a you
know a ton that happens and this is just
another example i mean we've seen it a
ton of times we saw it during blm in
2020 in the summer we saw it um
even even recently this past summer
there was uh there were protests uh that
were happening
um
here in l.a uh you know andy no was like
right posting a bunch of videos of stuff
that was happening and sharing is saying
it was antifa that was probably
fake faking faking the [ __ ] right
right but again you know you've got a
you've got a situation that gets
overly saturated with police
they
exert too much force
things escalate
uh it only like
and the thing is too is like it's the
cops that are pushing on themselves they
are the ones that are bringing
themselves to a boiling point right it's
their hot-headedness their
uh you know machismo it's that whole
thing of like i've got the power and
you're not respecting my power and well
yeah it's the authoritarian right it's
that threat
yeah you said something you yelled
something at me i'm going to hit you
with the [ __ ] billy club right that's
that's that's why a lot of these these
these police officers you know took took
this trumpism thing a little too far
when they went right january 6 but a lot
of them believe in this stuff because
trump would say something like yeah just
bash them over the head hit their head
over the top of the car you know they
they love they love this authoritarian
stuff right they love this authoritarian
state uh police officers you know that
culture that you're talking about right
and that's why i i actually don't think
we should defund the police i think we
should fund
actual training of police get rid of the
[ __ ] fascist in those police
departments pay police damn good
salaries and attract really good people
who want to actually do the job of being
a peacekeeper and and serving the public
not serving their own [ __ ] power trip
right um speaking speaking of uh
unwanted violence and ridiculous power
trips you remember do you remember um
the oscars this year there was an event
that happened where a really famous
actor i forget what his name is i think
his name is will something will smith
yeah will smith he went up on stage and
smacked the [ __ ] out of chris rock even
chris rock said will smith you smacked
the [ __ ] out of me right
um last night i believe and i'm not sure
where this is i think it's in hollywood
is that right another event here in l.a
um dave chappelle was almost tackled on
stage so let's watch this video here
yeah that happened at the hollywood bowl
yeah so this is um
this is video of it um i'm not going to
mute it let's watch this if you look
here
at the still image it looks like you
know a man standing up it's really hard
because this video is from far away but
this man standing up is supposedly dave
chappelle in this video it is really
hard to tell because it's so fast and so
far away but that this other guy looks
like he's tackling him watch this video
so it's really fast there but it looks
like this person tried to tackle deja vu
on stage it looked like you know lined
up like a like a football player and
just you know shoulder in trying to go
now you have some friends that are
stand-up comedians
obviously maybe not quite as famous as
as dave chappelle here but no person
should go up on stage no matter what
comedian no matter what they're saying
and assault someone i mean if you have a
if you're opposed to their opinion you
know sure shout something from the
audience yeah you can hackle if you want
to get kicked out of the event
right that you disagree with is not the
way forward right like we had a we had
what happened at trump rallies right
people like get that son of a [ __ ] out
of here i'll attack i'll pay for the
link that's the culture right right
we're going back to that culture
what happened in hollywood at the oscars
set a precedent to say if you don't like
what somebody says on stage
because you know they're paid to make a
joke then you can physically assault
them
and that's it now i'll tell you that
that apparently i and i don't know i
haven't read a lot of the police reports
and stuff um but supposedly in some of
the articles this this
this man who tried to tackle these
chabel may have had some weapons on him
possibly a firearm parsley a knife but i
want to show you what the hell happened
um to this guy this is supposedly him on
the gurney at the event after
he got the [ __ ] beat out of oh my god
because there's like i mean he is dave
chappelle so he has a lot of security
especially at an event like this where
there's a lot of people i mean they got
on this guy and it was very fast to
remove des chappelle
and i mean they subdued quote unquote
this guy but look at this guy on this
girl
i mean he looks like a goddamn pretzel
like literally they turned him into a
pretzel look at the arm right there oh
[ __ ] i don't i don't know if it was
such a good idea
to go try to assault dave chappelle and
this is seems like a really bad idea
yeah you can hear the crowd going ooh oh
god i mean it hurts just kind of looking
good yeah i know i i don't you know
again oh rather i don't know what state
this guy's in in terms of like why he
did what he did if it was because he
disagreed or
he has some mental problem or whatever
it is
but that's just one of those things
where it's like you do not do that also
the reason dave chappelle was in
hollywood and was performing at the
hollywood bowl is for a uh netflix is a
joke
siri like the show right right now now
dave chappelle has had some some
controversy right right and his and and
you can hate on dave chappelle but you
should not go assault him right yeah
yeah yeah and the thing that happened
was uh this is an this was happening
during the month of april and may which
is like comedians come out netflix hosts
this this uh
this series of shows right and you
perform and um he was performing at the
hollywood bowl for i think three nights
or whatever
but yeah it's just one of those things
where it's like
you know one
uh
if you feel a certain way
i'm sorry but
you paid to show up to watch that person
whatever your intent may be or your your
uh
your opinion of that person you pay to
attend that doesn't give you the right
to then go on stage in assault like the
the 200 ticket that you paid for to go
there because i i looked up tickets and
they were anywhere from like 65 to 200
to 200 plus so he was he was probably
somewhere up front well i mean right was
that well
when i looked up the middle section was
like 205. the further out like where the
video was filmed from is like a 65
section right right so
whatever the price that he paid or maybe
he got down and went to concession and
then found his way in i don't know
but he paid
65 to 200 or more
to go with salt uh dave chappelle yeah
which again
amanda amanda amanda points out a good a
good uh point here i hope uh will smith
is proud what he started this violence
on comedians because of him i think
amanda you're right i think i think this
now that any comedian any performer
really that's on stage that gets
assaulted is going to be blamed on will
smith and it's not his fault but he kind
of did it to himself to start this idea
that uh you know
smithing will smithing someone you know
right
i'm a snowflake i can't take a joke so i
gotta go on stage exactly
and i've got other friends who are
comedians and they have they feel the
same way that night that it happened i
was in touch with a few of them and
they're like great now this sets
right and he's like just because i say i
like and you know the people that are
telling jokes they're not telling jokes
that are like bigoted or anything like
that they're telling jokes that are you
know observational making fun of
obviously maybe a group that might be
trumpers or other republicans or things
like that
but whoever you might be on the spectrum
of the recipient of the joke
just because
you don't agree with it
doesn't give you the right to go tackle
them or hit them or whatever no caitlin
says his arm looked like a woody's from
toy story uh thanks for the super chat
yeah caitlyn yeah
it's specifically like a toy story too
like before he gets sewn back up you
know right right yeah right when he's he
he he obviously
met uh dave chappelle's security staff
up close and in person thanks for the
super really is one of those [ __ ] around
and find out and he found out real quick
right speaking of being will smith and
chris rock i guess chris rock was there
gabe he was there and here is a video of
chris rock's response to what just
happened on stage listen listen to this
there's the event
where she see him running
was that will smith
that's chris rock's response of course
chris rock um you know in in in in great
comedian fashion yeah he's still he's
still even though as serious as an event
as the oscars was he can still come out
on stage and make a joke about it and i
think that's i mean here's the thing all
he had to do was ask one like that was
the boom done like just dunked it and
did it you know all he had to do was ask
one question one line that's all he had
to do he knew exactly it was set up
and then he knew how to hit the punch
right right and and that's what makes
chris rock a great comedian right and
and the thing is um regardless of your
views of some some of these folks uh
chris rock dave chappelle they are they
are great comedians even though some of
their views are fun he hasn't even
touched on the subject yet right well he
just he just kind of did well yeah he
kind of did yeah yeah but i mean that's
the thing man i posted a george carlin
video about the abortion and people were
like oh you dumbass you look to
comedians to form your opinion i'm like
do you know what comedy actually is
these people actually don't know what
comedy is the truth is in the comedy
right and and the truth is that chris
rock was trying to make is this dumb
buck came up and thought he could
assault someone right like dave
chappelle on shays why he's working why
he's doing his job
just like will smith thought he could
come up on stage and insult chris rock
and that's why chris rock makes the joke
is that guy will smith because he's
saying will smith is just as dumb as
this ticket holder that came up on stage
and thought he could assault right dave
chappelle like that's the truth of the
matter he is making a joke about the
truth no one thank you for the uh super
sticker there we go thank you but the
other thing too is that people are like
oh oh no what do you what do communities
can do this you could you know rely on a
community it's like well here's the
thing comedians are jesters of the court
they can say what they want you know
within certain limits of protection
uh but they're the only ones that are
allowed you know in terms of like making
jokes about a king that could get away
with it and still have their life that's
right assuming they didn't go too far
with it but it is one of those things
where it's like yes comedians are able
to give us right insight and power and
truth
exactly well and that's you know a lot
of people don't understand the uh and
and really uh
the trump bumpers we talked about this
time and time again they destroyed
satire they destroyed comedy because
they they're such parodies of themselves
right and also super sensitive why can't
you take a joke well right somebody made
a joke and now you're super mad about it
and they can't handle the reason why is
because they can't handle the actual
truth that's right that's why that's the
whole trumpism that's that culture that
you know i'm a snowflake and i can't
handle the truth and it's too much and
speaking of that mj thank you for this
super sticker but
speaking of the the truth um here i want
to go to did you did you see that howard
what howard stern had said about this
supreme court decision yes i don't think
he's i think he's i think that's totally
fine i think he's spot on here um a lot
of people don't like howard stern for a
lot of different reasons um i i was
always a fan of howard because he is
provocative um and he's provocative in a
way that makes you think again kind of
like a comedian would make you think
about an issue but he really does get a
uh
he gets straight to the point here and
the reason why we have the situation
that we have and if you're wondering out
there why the situation is what it is
just listen to howard here and he'll
kind of explain it this really isn't
rocket science i mean he puts it in so
many words because howard stern is good
with words right but this isn't rocket
science of why we're in the situation he
just has a fabulous way of describing it
let's listen abortion come out how women
vote for this agenda is beyond me how
you would how who the hell wants to
carry a baby that you do not want
and again the people who uh carry these
uh babies who don't want them don't
raise these kids and then we're stuck
with them society is stuck with them the
people who are anti-abortion they don't
give to charity they don't raise these
kids i don't know who they think's going
to raise them
but um you know
you saw men if men got pregnant it would
be a different story no man would want
to be raped and then have to carry his
rapists uh baby
uh i think i think that's probably one
of one of the best points that he makes
in this uh this little two-minute clip
here is that look if this was reversed
and men had the burden of the state
telling them what medical procedure they
can and cannot get and forcing them to
carry
uh a baby to term this this would be
completely different totally
we would not even be having this
discussion because this opinion would
not even exist the only reason why it
exists is because men want to [ __ ]
tell women what the [ __ ] they want to do
because that's the truth of the matter
that we have here is it is men in this
country
[ __ ] freak ass men wanting weirdos
[ __ ] weirdos that they are so
concerned with a woman's vagina why are
you so concerned with a woman's body you
[ __ ] weirdo they're very concerned
with something that they probably won't
get that's right let's just be honest
about it right i mean i mean man they're
they're completely obsessed with
people's genitalia and bathrooms it's
the same [ __ ] it's the same
minority who want to ban macbooks
because it's crt it's the same minority
that want to tell lgbtq people what the
[ __ ] they can and can't do
and who they can love and who they can
marry and what they can identify as this
is really [ __ ] these are [ __ ]
weirdos they're fascist but they're
weirdos and howard stern has it right on
the head that there's no [ __ ] way
that men in this country would let some
[ __ ] weirdo ass men tell them what
they could and couldn't do about their
own pregnancy let me tell you that is
one [ __ ] thing that men would
not put up with this in this country and
women shouldn't either and us men should
not put up with [ __ ] men telling
women what to do either that's for
goddamn sure because they'll come for
you next and they're coming for women's
contraception that's the next step but
let's listen to what howard says how he
wraps it up in a bow here um men we're
ready to tear this country down because
we ask them to wear a mask let alone
have some baby they don't want yeah but
okay how did we get to this point the
electoral college says and i guess this
was set up back in the good old days
because they wanted everyone to have
some kind of representation but here's
what happened three million voters
were the majority who voted for hillary
clinton but they ended up with trump we
got a minority president
who held views that were the minority of
this country
so much so that he lost by three million
votes and he became president
and then he did the country of favor and
found the most radical supreme court
justices who all agreed
that abortion was now he alludes to it
here but he didn't find the most radical
uh the most radical supreme court
justice were bought and paid for and
placed on a list and donald trump was
forced that was the deal he made with
the devil was that he would pick the
supreme court justice from the
federalist society that's why all the
evangelical christians backed this [ __ ]
grabbing three-time married [ __ ]
non-christian dave they elected him
because he agreed to make sure that this
what we're going through right now what
happened i mean if anyone wants to get
mad at anyone people should be looking
to people like george conway all right i
think he's your friend you know he's
like oh who he's a never trumper no man
george conway is nobody's friend he will
at any moment turn his back on you and
then also simultaneously stab it but uh
he is you know huge i think he had a
tweet yesterday that was pushing
why this decision was was so correct
right it's ahead and saying that roe
versus wade had regressed the
advancement of of women's rights you
know which is insane because it's the
complete opposite and so george conway
you know one of the people the federal
society the one of the people like tony
said who are the are the you know not
going to say they're the puppeteers but
they are the people that are [ __ ]
pushing and and pain and
and making sure that
certain people are in power they're
lining those things up it's like how do
you think we got to where we are right
now it's because those people were the
ones who were funding it those are the
people ones who are making the decision
right right and they just got pissed off
right they just got pissed off that it
didn't happen the way that they wanted
it to happen yeah and that christo makes
a good point here heritage foundation
too yeah yeah mayo says you know just
like his wife kellyanne conway right
another
demon in uh human form
but
yeah she was yeah oh my god
but yeah
again you know what these groups are you
know privately funded right wing fascist
think tanks organizations
foundations whatever you want to call
them but they're the ones that are you
know i mean
the rest of dc is also funded in certain
ways but these are the people if you
want to look at who is the who is
responsible for pushing this type of
this uh type of opinion that has been
dissented you know um you got to look at
george conway kellyanne conway the
heritage foundation the federal society
like these are the people
that are the ones that are pushing the
buttons someone on twitch here says the
[ __ ] keeper you shouldn't know
you shouldn't call kellyanne conway the
crypt how dare you on my show that is an
insult to the crypt keeper that is an
insult that's right the crypt keeper
should be offended by what you just said
let's listen to what uh the rest of
howard stern's argument here of the
scotus draft decision wrong they've been
on some sort of a secret list that not
so secret list
so we ended up with this scenario
and we also ended up with it when
again
you know uh obama didn't get to pick a
supreme court justice so okay so now we
have a minority viewpoint in this
country running the country if it was
the majority viewpoint all right you put
up with it but it's the minority
viewpoint now how much more are we going
to take
how much more of this [ __ ]
that some hillbilly in south dakota gets
a more important vote because he lives
in south dakota now that is a really a
really good point what he's alluding to
there is the way that we elect the
president
is that the the people in south dakota
are in the 2016 election were reported
way more sway with their vote than
everyone else because it is true that we
get one person one vote in this country
but because of how our uh our republic
works and the presidential election
works especially um there is more weight
for people in
uh areas where
there is less votes um where there's a
higher population now of course like the
state of new york and the state of
california receive more electoral votes
for the college but
that still doesn't matter when you're
talking about if you put together the
right states that someone can lose by
three million votes and still become
president yeah now a lot of people want
to abolish uh that part of our election
system and actually i think the easiest
way is to not abolish it i think the
easiest way is to
um there is a project out there that is
trying to get states to pass their law
to where their state
actually gives their votes for the
college to the majority vote in their
state and as long as we get uh enough
states to do that the the popular vote
in the country should be right who the
president actually becomes rather
whether it's republican democrat or
otherwise if we that's how it should be
right it makes total sense right like
you wouldn't just default and say
all right uh yeah we're gonna go with
the electoral college if you don't win
the popular vote then you know in the
popular vote but it's like wait wouldn't
that be the majority of people those are
the people who that is the majority of
the population of the united states who
said hey
uh we want this person to be in power we
have we have put our voice on the ballot
and our vote has gone to this person and
then what basically what our electoral
college system says is yeah yeah that's
that's nice that you decided that but
we're gonna go a different way right
like you're you know you're just
throwing throwing these people saying
that like oh everyone has a voice and
everyone has the right to vote and and
you want to make your you want to make
your voice your vote you know
uh established and heard right but this
is one of those moments where you look
at he's like yeah we'll [ __ ] those votes
right right well chris chris points out
chris from youtube points out a good
point here uh we need to do ranked
choice voting as well uh some states do
rank choice voting like maine does
ranked choice voting and some other
things and if you guys don't know what
ranked choice voting is go go google it
rank choice voting um it's a very unique
way to make sure that you rank your
candidates so in other words if there's
four candidates on the ballot or there's
six candidates on the ballot you know it
gets rid of this whole third party
[ __ ] argument um we we really can
toss that [ __ ] to the side if we get to
ranked choice voting in some of these
dates but amanda i'm going to push back
a little bit she says abolish the
electoral college i think there's a way
to actually circumvent the electoral
college in our laws without having to i
think abolishing it is a lot tougher
than actually getting states to say
we are going to give our electoral votes
to the majority of the vote in our state
if this because the state can decide
that the state can pass that law to do
that it is constitutional so there's a
constitutional way to make sure
in this country enough states have to
decide to do that and i i believe it's
only like three or four states away is
kind of the the math so wait wait are
you saying that
we should support states rights
well you know i think i think what we
should do is if the state has the right
to choose how they afford their
electoral college votes then we should
do that but when it comes to someone's
liberty when it comes to someone's
liberty because you get the vote now
they the state does not have the right
to keep you from voting right the state
does not keep you have the right despite
the fact that republicans try to do that
right well i mean i mean i talked about
the 19th amendment yesterday do you know
what the 19th amendment is
the exact wording no no the 19th
amendment is the amendment that afforded
women the right to vote right yeah yeah
and i believe suffrage 1920 correct
correct and
was it 22. no it's not 1919 1920 i
believe it was ratified in 1920. so it
became official right exactly it was
passed in 1919 and then ratified about
about a year later i believe once the
states ratified it but here we are
almost 100 years over 100 years later
and i'm telling you the next thing is
contraception and then they're going to
come after the women's vote and
everyone's like oh they can't they can't
because of the 19th amendment they go oh
they go after
black people's vote all the time people
of color's vote is at jeopardy all the
time with these [ __ ] gqp fascists
just because you're white doesn't mean
you're safe just because they can't just
say women can't vote doesn't mean they
won't try to take away your ability to
that is such [ __ ] they are coming
after your right to vote and the reason
why i know they're coming after women's
right to vote is because the the the
absolute uproar you're going to see
about this decision yeah on roe v wade
you're going to see an uproar and
they're going to figure out that holy
[ __ ] are our
our constituency is at risk right so we
got to make sure to pare down our
constituents
the men are the men are speaking the men
are voting exactly right please that's
right let us let let us finish go back
to the kitchen simmer down simmer down
now go make me a sandwich that's what
they want right don't vote don't speak
out don't protest just go back into the
kitchen
take a little drug to make you calm
and i'll see you at dinner right keep
that aspirin between your legs and you
know and when you do have an abortion
[ __ ] you right and let's hear what
howard says here about about the
unwanted babies this is this is a great
dismount here for this clip let's hear
what he has to say about what we should
do with all all the unwanted babies
um that these fascists want to want to
have in our country
uh let me tell you something here's what
i say all unwanted children should be
allowed to live at the supreme court
building with those justices and they
should raise every one of those babies
that crackpot uh clarence thomas and
that wife and all of them they can raise
these babies that they want that's right
and and i i i don't i i think that maybe
uh a supreme court uh uh nursery is not
a bad idea i mean if they're gonna pass
this law maybe we should put it on them
yeah i mean for the same people that are
like we gotta protect the children
we gotta we gotta keep them safe we
gotta make sure that they're not being
trafficked it's like all right well uh i
don't see you adopting
you know oh pro-life pro-life i don't
see you giving them the resources or or
the money or the organization or or the
programs to make sure that a single
parent a mother that you forced to have
a child get the actual support that she
needs because at the end of the day
that's what's happening right they look
at this and they say oh you know what
you have to have the baby you're like
okay cool fine
you forced me to have the baby right
despite the fact that i want to you made
me have the baby are you gonna give me
the proper resources to help me prepare
the home
to give me the the uh you know the the
tools
to raise this child right the funds to
help raise them so i don't find myself
in crushing debt outside of the fact
that i just you know went to school and
now i'm already in crushing debt but now
like okay i got to raise another life on
top of my own and make sure that i care
for it will you give me the funds will
you will you point me to the right
program and an organization that will
help me with this and they're like oh
you know what actually we just closed
down the most uh the most recent planned
parenthood that was closest to you right
yeah you're like okay well you're gonna
you have another place that i can go no
actually the next one's uh two states
over right and you're like well
what do i do
and then like oh well go get [ __ ] go
get bent go get bent yeah right oh yeah
and when you have the baby when you have
the baby that baby can get bent too
we're not gonna help right exactly
speaking speaking of the supreme court
and the lying lying [ __ ] fascist
bought and paid for supreme court
justices did you see the video that
might has touch
uh but i just say lion gop it's it's
trending as you guys know we're midas
touch partners you may be watching from
the minus touch facebook page right now
and if you are make sure to click the
link at the top of the post and go to
our youtube page
and subscribe to our youtube channel
you're not going to want to miss a thing
over here
on our youtube channel
but mine minus touch had this video
lying gop yesterday
um which i think
really does describe
what
what has happened what howard stern kind
of describes as the minority rule in
this country the prop the problem that
we have and i actually said this in the
beginning of the broadcast game that
i don't believe that our country is
divided everyone's like oh we're divided
like 50 50 like no that's all [ __ ]
yeah that's all [ __ ] that's actually
the fraud that trump has wrought on us
is that somehow we're a 50 50 divide
that is all [ __ ] even even
abolishing roe v wade doesn't even get
30 in some of these red states where you
would believe that that 90 of people
would want to abolish abortion which is
all [ __ ] people don't want to get
rid of it no the reason why is because
even pro-lifers have abortions right
they have medical procedures that are
considered abortions like literally
they have [ __ ] at stake in
contraception for crying out loud like
literally they have a stake in their
family's planning and how these [ __ ]
pro-lifers can't get this through their
thick [ __ ] skull that it's not about
a [ __ ] a fetus it's not about a
partial birth abortion which is not a
thing that's all [ __ ] you have been
lied to just like you q anon bucks have
been lied to you have been lied to for
decades and decades and you believe [ __ ]
that just is categorically not true
and here's the thing most people
understand just like they understand
with uh issues like gay marriage or or
people wanting to identify as a certain
gender or who they [ __ ] or who they love
it it's not their [ __ ] business it's
not their [ __ ] business and if it's
not their [ __ ] business what should
they give a [ __ ] and how and they do not
want someone else telling them what the
[ __ ] to do especially the government
but here we have here we have a video
here about the supreme court justices
that are going to overturn
um the liberty of women in this country
take away their [ __ ] rights which is
really a president in this in this day
and age that the supreme court would
take away your rights um but they keep
doing it more and more often but let's
listen to this video that mind has
touches put together i believe the
constitution protects the right to
privacy
and i have no reason or agenda to
prejudge the issue
[Music]
roe versus wade is an important
precedent of the supreme court it was
decided in 1973
it has been challenged on a number of
occasions and the supreme court has
reaffirmed the decision when a decision
is challenged and it is reaffirmed that
strengthens its value
roe versus wade decided in 1973
as the price of the united states
supreme court it has been reaffirmed so
a good judge will consider it as
precedent of the united states supreme
court worthy as treatment of president
like any other
[Music]
as a judge it is an important precedent
of the supreme court by it i mean roe v
wade and planned parenthood versus casey
been reaffirmed many times
casey is precedent on precedent
[Music]
i do not believe that brett kavanaugh
will overturn presidents are overturned
all the time
they aren't overturned all the time he
views precedent not just as a legal
doctrine but is rooted in our
constitution neil gorsuch for whom you
voted don't you think he's probably
going to vote to overturn roe vs wade if
given the chance i actually don't
rowe is not a super president because
calls for its overruling have never
seeped but that doesn't mean that rose
should be overruled
so there you have it
midas touch put together another great
video about the lying gop
um and and all these justices that
[ __ ] lied they're [ __ ] liars
they had to lie no one's going to
approve that right right
right because the majority of the
country doesn't want that [ __ ] right and
they know it but they know it
they have to lie like you said to get on
the court so they can press their views
uh amanda says here my mother got a
mammogram at planned parenthood and
saved your life by finding a lump at
stage one
because that's the rub that's the rub
they want to defund places where that is
saving lives let me give you let me let
me give you a personal story here about
planned parenthood
um we were gonna try to have a second
child my wife had an iud
we're sinners gabe we were using birth
control
you left us that's [ __ ] socialist
bastard right we were trying to plan our
family
and here's what happened we wanted to
have another child okay
what she had in iud she had to have the
iud removed
and to do that she had to have an
appointment with i don't know what are
they called doctors oh
to make it safe right you know so it can
be safely removed by someone who is
trained to do it in a safe environment
so that her health wasn't at risk
well she set an appointment but it was
pretty far out but she she found a
planned parenthood that was close by
that would do it sooner so she decided
okay i'll go to the planned parenthood
and by the way it was a lot cheaper at
the planned parenthood than it was at
the other doctor's office right they
provided at a much more affordable cost
for us now remember we are wanting to
have a baby right right not to get rid
of a baby yeah not to partial birth a
baby you [ __ ] morons we wanted to
have a baby
we wanted to bring a child into the
world so my wife set an appointment at
that abortion clinic that kills babies
no
she set an appointment at a medical
clinic to make sure that her iud was
removed safely so we could proceed to
have another child right you dumb
[ __ ] and here's what happened
this is the craziest part about this
story my wife goes to the planned
parenthood for her appointment
and when she pulls in of course there's
all these [ __ ] whack jobs with signs
and everything right they're yelling and
screaming there's a huge huge line out
on the [ __ ] sidewalk because they
can't go on private property because you
can't protest on private property
exactly it's a public thing you have to
protest in public so they're out on the
sidewalk they're blocking the driveway
she pulls in to the planned parenthood
she parks
and a security guard
like hightails it to her car
has her roll down the window and say hey
i'm going to escort you in
when she gets out of the car to go into
this medical
facility to to remove her iud so that
she can have a baby right these people
are yelling at her calling her a baby
killer and don't let them kill your baby
all kinds of just complete [ __ ]
nonsense not knowing that my wife is
actually going into the facility to
create life to safely have her birth
control removed that she had so that way
she could have a baby and carry it to
full term they really are [ __ ]
knuckleheads they're young capoop nazis
they do not understand that planned
parenthood and thank you amanda for
bringing it up planned parenthood is not
an abortion clinic
it is a [ __ ] clinic that provides
health care mainly to women right and
young women at that not just not just
women but even younger women who can't
get health care anywhere else in some of
their communities well they just can't
afford it they're just idiots they don't
know one from the other they hear
republicans and other you know lawmakers
say oh they're trying to kill babies and
that's what planned parenthood does it's
like no it's actually a place where they
can get the proper uh guidance on any
matters that relate to to women's public
health right like i want to get i want
to know what i should do for
contraception which can be used for many
different purposes right outside of just
uh
of of not wanting to get pregnant right
but then there's also things like oh me
as a woman i want to know you know uh
specific topics or questions that i want
to be answered and i want a woman
or or you know male doctor too but a
doctor who is a professional in this
in this
in this specialty to tell me what i
should or i shouldn't do what i should
do or what should i avoid or what have
you like give me the proper guidance
give me the idea i should seek an expert
when you're when you're talking about
medical
uh
look you could do your own research but
sometimes the research should come from
someone who's an expert you definitely
want to go on facebook and find a group
that tells you how to do it yourself
like you know go to the feed store and
get you some some more space didn't eat
that that'll keep keep you from being
disease-free i mean it'll keep the worms
away you definitely yeah worm definitely
be warm do you do you know who andy andy
duffer is he does some tic tacs oh yeah
andy jeffrey yeah he's a comedian
he's in a southern state tennessee yeah
i think so i think so but he did this
video
um yesterday on this supreme court
justice draft decision and it is [ __ ]
hilarious and i i don't know why i don't
understand why it doesn't have more
views so i'm gonna play it here because
i think it's fantastic let's listen to
andy here what's up [ __ ] welcome to
my bed this is where i sin and slumber
and that's um
that's a naked picture of me
is it narcissistic to have a naked
picture of yourself above your face yes
just like women have bodies and a choice
or at least they should a lot of you
have been asking me to make a video
about the roe vs wade news and i really
only have one thing to say about it the
only time that a man should speak about
women's rights is when he is in support
of them that's it that's the [ __ ] t i
genuinely don't give a flying [ __ ] about
your religious beliefs if you want to
talk about your religious beliefs go to
church but your religious beliefs don't
belong inside of a woman's uterus
it is a woman's right to choose
abortion is an essential component of
women's health care i don't care how you
feel that's a [ __ ] fact
what's up [ __ ]
i think the other thing too here is like
you bring you bring in
he he makes a great point throughout the
whole thing uh he does really great
rants where he like walks in like
circles in his living room you know and
has them so perfectly timed with like
what's shown on the screen on the tv
behind him but i want to say in this
moment right now like completely right
right like keep your religion keep your
beliefs out of a woman's uterus i would
also say that the majority of men who
want to dictate what a woman can and
can't do with said reproductive rights
uh could not identify on a map for the
same way that charlie kirk couldn't
identify
a a baby versus a dolphin baby that was
in the womb right like this is the type
of expert that they have they're the
type of men who should be dictating what
you can do what you can't do as a woman
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you should have no
way because again you're probably still
searching for the [ __ ] sorry well i
danny here he's in he's in the comments
he's trolling hard and everyone's
pointing out that he's holding throwing
on this guy this guy must have trouble
looking for the [ __ ] too i would imagine
yeah this guy's all over my twitter too
if anyone if anyone wants to make sure
to give danny [ __ ] here danny thinks he
can come on our show and he's like oh
we'll just block trolls guess what
[ __ ] we don't block trolls we
point you out because we'd like to have
you we love that you come hate watch
here danny i hope you come every single
day and hate watch me and comment and
boost our algorithms and really get us
out into the world of you [ __ ] who
can't find a woman's [ __ ] if it sat on
your face yeah you [ __ ] snowflake
[ __ ] that's sure he's also that you
know he's saying that oh get real
butthurt i'm also pretty sure that yeah
oh danny
probably couldn't tell the difference
between a vagina and an [ __ ] that
it's funny he thinks he's going to come
he thinks he's going to come [ __ ] with
the couple [ __ ] libs who are who are
soft and you know he's always in my
twitter comments he thinks he's cool
right
he's he come here to watch the show and
danny come back every single day we're
live danny every single day youtube
twitter twitch and now on the mind touch
facebook page please go to all those
channels and leave your comment danny go
troll in all those places so you can
really help us boost the algorithms we
have a lot of hate watchers here danny
and we love to engaged yeah we love that
you're right yeah get it share it to
your friends we love you troll hating
women friends like
show them who we are well he'll leave
now now that we pointed him out captain
turpin is a danny dip dipstick yeah
he'll definitely he'll definitely leave
now that we pointed out this is what
happens you know i get people attack me
and they think they're cool in the
comments they'll attack me and then what
i do is what i do folks is i bring them
up and we challenge them because i'm not
[ __ ] i'm not scared of a bunch of
trump pumping trolls i'm not scared of
you you stupid [ __ ] and i mean
yesterday if you think you're going to
intimidate us with your views you're
wrong we're going to say our views here
on our show the way that we want to say
them with the gusto that we want to say
chris chris in here we love chris and he
is one of our hate watchers thank you
chris for staying with us for yeah for
months and months right you got to earn
it man you got to earn it [ __ ]
i get people every day that come into my
twitter comments also that send me
facebook or instagram dms or or or
comments you should invite them to the
show yeah well i mean what i do is i
comment to say oh you know you're an
idiot for these reasons right and then
and then they block
they say something i respond then they
block me and i go well i guess that's
that
all right you know for a group that
calls other people snowflakes you're
real sensitive right right and i don't
even say anything bad i just call you
out on your [ __ ] well it happens
when you call them out you call them out
um uh so let's let's go to let's see
what else do we you know what you know
what um how are you working on that jd
mandel you guys know that the trump
endorsed jd mandel candidate might be
joining us today right are we are we
closer to his folks saying yeah yeah let
me uh
yeah he should should we go to a break
we'll go to a break and then uh and then
we'll come right back yeah i'll try to
coordinate uh the to get him on okay
good good let's take a break when we
come back um soon after that we will
have we will have jd mandel the actual
trump endorsed candidate
in ohio we know that jd vance won maybe
we'll ask jd vance
i'm gonna give him a call right now all
right sounds good we'll be right back
after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow
so we can circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob i'm fixing to send you some
more of them doritos you like the red
bag not the lib loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong
wipe your ass at least once a day
here's
tammy
[ __ ] him
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for joining us here on the tony
michael's podcast
every single weekday monday through
friday
even the hate watchers are here today
we broadcast live from youtube twitter
and twitch and now from the midas touch
facebook page if you are listening to us
out there go subscribe to the youtube
channel
and get in the chat on youtube you do
not want to miss it we have all the hate
watchers over here
and you know what happens after after we
after we get done doing the live show
and we record the live show
i then put the audio up on you excuse me
spotify apple and google is what i meant
to say where you can download the
episode every single day
so not only do you get to watch my
beautiful
face and participate in the great chat
over here on youtube you guys chat on on
facebook too i shouldn't discount the
chat on facebook you guys are great over
there on facebook on my facebook page
but come over to the super chat here on
um
on youtube
and you guys can see all the hate
watching trolls we usually have some
trolls on on the facebook page too i'm
not gonna discount the facebook page we
usually have the trolls there
as well
uh mj points out um something here let
me see if i can find that comment back
uh she says two hours is starting to go
by really fast it is starting to go by
really fast we are we are almost 20
minutes
into the second hour so far and we
haven't even got started yet
looks like we're gonna have jd mandel do
you guys remember who jd mandela is
you guys remember jd mandel
you know the guy who uh trump actually
supported or at least that's who he
thought he was supporting
trump did
you remember this guy he's going to be
joining us soon but i want to show you
in the meantime why we're waiting on uh
gabe to get jd mandela and his people in
an interview i want to show you a a a
video from yesterday of speaking of
being pissed
of elizabeth warren i don't know did you
guys see this elizabeth warren
was super pissed um watch this video
here she goes the [ __ ] off watch this
how are you feeling i am angry angry
angry and upset and determined the
united states congress can keep rovers
away the law of the land they just need
to do it i've never seen you so angry
you seem to be this is what
the republicans have been working toward
this day for decades they have been out
there plotting
carefully cultivating these supreme
court justices so they could have a
maturity on the bench who would
accomplish something that the majority
of americans do not want
69 percent of people across this country
across this country red states and blue
states old people and young people want
roe versus wade to maintain
this number two and we
need to know we're not we have a right
dismembering
us we've earned enough for every
what a great fantastic video from
elizabeth warren warren standing up for
women's rights there and saying hey look
[ __ ]
you're not gonna just you're not just
gonna skate by
on dismissing the entire the majority of
americans opinions here and that's
really the rub here
and and i'm going to show you another
video here of a of a couple [ __ ]
slime balls
of
what their plan is because elizabeth
warren alludes to it
their plan that meticulous plan
and i said on this tweet i said listen
to ron johnson lay out how the gqp views
every wedge issue this is every single
[ __ ] wedge issue that they consider
even even danny boy here is saying it in
the chat this is how they view every
single [ __ ] wedge issue
every [ __ ] one of them a heartland
signal had this video it says on rumble
which is such a [ __ ] box
[ __ ] swamp to live in it's like it's
like the getter of youtube the true
social youtube
uh anti-backs are uh todd calendar which
i don't know who the [ __ ] this guy is
other than he's a [ __ ] anti-vaxxer
but you should see you should hear some
of the vile [ __ ] that this [ __ ]
says the craziest part
is ron johnson is talking to this vile
[ __ ] what in the [ __ ] would a
united states senator
give any [ __ ] two shits what a vile
[ __ ] like this would say
what
let's just listen and then listen to
what ron johnson says
because ron johnson says oh your ideas
aren't wrong
it just might take a while to implement
watch this [ __ ] the way to approach this
is from a criminal point of view because
that's what has happened and until we
start holding people accountable fouchy
number one now now i i want to give some
context here this has to do with the the
vaccine right
but their view
what ron johnson says and this guy's
vile view
is [ __ ] is the is the
it's the [ __ ] same thing they do on
every goddamn issue
every [ __ ] every fascist issue that
they want to take your [ __ ] rights
away and they want their fascist state
to tell you what you can and cannot do
that's what the [ __ ] this is because
look you had a choice in this country
you dumb [ __ ] to get the
vaccine or not you either chose to get
it or you chose not to get it
and you live with the consequences
you live with the [ __ ] consequences
if you got it or didn't get it the
consequence of getting it is yeah you
felt sick for a few days
but you're not going to be hospitalized
and die more than likely the chances are
very [ __ ] low that you would if you
contracted covid
the risk and consequence of not getting
it is obviously the disease itself but
also you may not do the things that you
want to do because private industry says
you can't do them without being
vaccinated
let's listen to this vile piece of [ __ ]
and his
i i
the most punchable face maybe on the
internet today is this chandler
chandler [ __ ] i don't know what the [ __ ]
his name is [ __ ] this guy
um you're gonna see people still falling
out still getting sick you've got more
than 100 doctors here all of whom will
tell you that these shots caused
vaccine-induced aids
this guy is claiming
that the vaccine
causes aids now not only not only is he
creating a wedge issue
with the vaccine
but he's also he's also clearly having
the trope
to attack the other people
right he's doing it he's doing it right
out in the open they they purposefully
gave people aids
right they knew this the fda two weeks
prior to their emergency abuse
authorization licenses had an internal
review what a wild piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
they had the infamous page 16. they went
on [ __ ] live they licensed these
shots anyway
even the [ __ ] vile [ __ ] lies
listen to what senator ron johnson
putin's puppet
he's got putin's head so his head so far
up putin's ass that he went and
celebrated 4th of july with putin
listen to what this [ __ ] says he
agrees with this guy but he agrees with
him but
and then you have the trickery with uh
interchangeable or not and is it a
legally distinct thing or not this is
criminal intent
and until we address this as being that
we're stuck we're we're not going to get
over this
let me challenge you there please
you think he's going to challenge his
ideas right like ron johnson started let
me challenge you let me push back on you
a bit you think you think he's gonna
challenge his ideas and ain't even close
to what this [ __ ] does watch
that's way down the road you gotta do
one step at a time i mean you gotta do
one step at a time oh it's not that i
don't agree with everything you just
said but you can't do it that fast like
we can't arrest we can't arrest fauci
tomorrow we gotta do it one step at a
time it's gonna take you know 20 30
years of really chipping away buying
supreme court justices making sure that
we have the right people in place to
[ __ ]
to to advance our fascist ideas listen
to what he says
everything you say may be true okay but
right now the public views the vaccines
is largely safe and effective that
vaccine injuries are rare and mild that
is the narrative that's what the vast
majority of the public accepts that is
the narrative that is what the public
except that's the [ __ ] truth
oh god these [ __ ]
so when we until we get a larger
percentage of the population with their
eyes open to
whoa oh jesus these vaccine issues are
real why
you know
step by step you can't you gotta dilute
the public you gotta dilute the public
it takes a while to convince him a [ __ ]
like queuing on
dr q anon or whatever this guy's name is
todd todd calendar i guess [ __ ] this guy
and [ __ ] ron johnson even harder [ __ ]
that guy that son of a [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
box
the united states senator would give any
kind of air to this idea that the
vaccine causes aids you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it gets me pissed off it gets me pissed
off you know what let's listen to
a video that might that might make
um you feel better about this issue
because i i think we we dismissed that a
little bit
we dismissed that a little bit that that
we should have some hope that the hope
is in us and our fight
for women's rights and liberty and
speaking of that
someone who's fought for women's rights
and liberty for her entire life i this
video from from morgan fairchild here
um
gives you gives you warmth about this
issue
even though we do need to fight back we
watched a
a video yesterday from jojo from jurors
and she said the same thing it's
devastating it's sad yes
we know this we knew what they were
gonna do
we can't we cannot stop we have to fight
back and we have to keep fighting for
people's liberty in this country hi guys
it's morgan here
well today is a very big day for those
of us who believe in a woman's right to
choose i'm one of those
i've been active on this issue for 40
years so we've seen this coming for a
long time
now it looks like it's here so for all
those years that i said look at the
courts before you vote
it's here honey
[Laughter]
so
i just want you to know that we are
bound in love together we will step
forward together united get involved
vote find a candidate you like get
behind them donate volunteer and vote
the only way we change this country is
to be very very involved and not take
anything for granted ever again
sending you lots and lots of love
we are in this together and it is the
fight of a lifetime
lots of love mwah
so there's morgan she's not going to
give up the fight and neither should you
and that's what i said morgan is still
in the fight you should be too
um make sure
you you
you go and follow morgan fairchild um
such a
such a great voice for women's rights
she's been fighting for probably 40
years 40 years for this cause um so it's
i'm very special
to see that she's still fighting and
she's not going to give up um kate
[Laughter]
uh i have to show this this is hilarious
of course katie porter we know about the
um
the whiteboard that the meme here [ __ ]
around and find out uh kate says the
women of twitter channeled to katie
porter today and i think that needs to
we need to do more of that
we need to have more of that
we gotta get it we can't just tweet we
gotta get in the streets
don't just tweet get in the streets i
don't know we're gonna come up with a
rhyme
for that somewhere here uh let's go to
the timeline uh
lincoln project had a video of uh of jd
vance did you guys know that jd vance
won the primary in ohio you know he was
supposedly the red the
trump back candidate but somehow someway
[Music]
um jd mandel
became the trump back candidate all of a
sudden
let's play this this ad by
lincoln project i think it's hilarious
the lincoln project salutes our fellow
never trump activists jd vance he led
the way in opposing trump in 2016 even
calling trump our hitler jd vance
speculated that trump might be america's
hitler trump is the fruit of the party's
collective neglect i go back and forth
between thinking trump is a cynical
a-hole like nixon or that he's america's
hitler
are you a racist jd joined john kasich
as the only major republicans in ohio to
vote against donald trump in 2016 and he
boldly told the truth about trump voters
we are whether we like it or not the
party of lower income lower education
white people trump is cultural heroine
fellow christians everyone is watching
us when we apologize for this man jd
vance is a multi-millionaire big tech
banker with a degree from yale our kind
of candidate he gets it
jd vance for sending the lincoln project
candidate
so there you see there you see uh uh jd
vance
uh as the never trump
candidate uh you know jd vance uh
appeared to have
trump's
uh support right he appeared to have his
his backing his endorsement
but when we when we seen him on stage at
the last trump rally it was someone else
and i'm just getting word here i'm just
getting word here i think i think that
person who trump endorsed uh is joining
us now um his name is jd mandel jd
mandel is that is that you
yes hi jd mandel thank you for having me
jd how how are you how are you uh you
know um
uh i i you know i've had better days you
know what what does your hat what does
your hat say
it says uh donald trump knows my name
okay okay so i mean he he called me out
you know we i'm gonna i'm gonna say this
um really didn't expect it but this past
weekend he called me out by name at the
ohio rally yeah i mean i think i think
it really pushed me in the polls a
little bit um so
you know i appreciate the uh the shout
out well um maybe we'll pull up that
video here of of trump um actually
um endorsing you what appears to be
endorsing you on stage
i mean i'd love to hear my name you know
yeah jd mandel
let's well he he kind of got your name
wrong there at first jade yeah you know
he's an older guy you know he said you
know he mixed up the d and the p but he
got there but he got right there right
so let's let's listen let's listen to
your mussolini jesus as it appears
you're a trump supporter right you love
trump he supports me so i support him oh
okay so that's how it is you know yeah
it's kind of a circle jerk kind of thing
i get it i get it sounds like trumpism
um so here here is here is your
mussolini jesus uh appearing to say your
name that's what they're waiting for
they're waiting for one race you know
we've endorsed dr oz we've endorsed
jp right j.d mandel here i am and he's
doing great they're all doing good he
said you were doing great there uh jd
mandel
oh man you know again i wasn't really
expecting it but as soon as does that
give you a boner it really seems like it
gave you a boner there
i mean you if you hear your name said by
trump on stage in front of you know a
few dozen people it is quite a trip oh
okay well it might be for someone who
thinks he's uh the republican jesus but
for someone who doesn't
anyway so let's get back to the other
people in this race were you how many
votes did you receive yesterday
um in the ohio primary
like counting my own
did you write yourself in is that what
you're saying uh i did i mean my name
wasn't officially on the ballot but
oh i took an advantage of an opportunity
and i i you know i was a write-in you
went ahead and voted for yourself yep
yep okay well that that makes sense
because you know you had a couple other
opponents on the ballot you actually had
jd vance which is i think who trump
originally endorsed are you aware of
that and he kind of shares the same
first yeah
but you know what
i guess he just knew that a uh a prado
ohio and like myself uh yeah should be
the candidate okay well there's also
another guy on the ballot that appears
to have a similar name as yours his name
is josh mandel so j is his first initial
i don't know if p is his middle initial
or not i have no idea but his last name
is mandel so he shares the same last
name a lot of people i will say this a
lot of people are saying that josh
mandel photoshopped himself into uh
photos uh while serving you know if you
look at his hands they're a little bit
darker than his skin some people said he
photoshopped himself so so you don't
like josh mandel you're not you're not
no no no no is is is he your cousin or
something you know you guys share the
last name i didn't know if like it was
your cousin no i mean look i'm not gonna
do the 23andme and try to figure out our
relationship but from what i understand
we are not related
um sure hope not um
but uh no i am my own man and uh i at
least for the most of what i know we are
not related we just happen to be you
know a couple mandels in one town you
know
ah just a couple mandels in the same
town well that's that's very interesting
uh so how do you think because it
appears that jd vance is going to win
the primary he's going to be the
republican candidate on the uh ballot
for the midterm election even though he
you probably did you see the the lincoln
project ad i just played where he's a
never trumper that he's been a never
trumper for a long time yeah
uh jd vance is a backstabbing hypocrite
oh he is okay well
so so you're saying i know he stole my
girlfriend in high school oh he did he
did this is news this is news everyone
breaking news
uh jd vance stole jd mandel's
girlfriend in high school and it seems
like you're very upset about this i am i
mean i i really thought we were gonna go
the distance you know we were gonna get
married we're gonna have kids we're
gonna get that you and you and jd are
you in this this
lovely lady oh my well my girlfriend and
i wanted her to be my wife i thought it
was really going to be that you know
we're a couple high school sweethearts
and uh you know jd
uh pretended to be this jd oh um you
know
so this isn't the first time he's trying
to impersonate you i guess i mean look
we were at a party okay we were playing
seven minutes in heaven okay i was
supposed to go in there with my
girlfriend okay okay
and then the next thing i know i'm going
to get us a couple drinks i'm like
where's lindsay and they said they're in
the closet together with jd and i said
what do you mean and you're like yeah
you say i'm jd i'm jade and i said i'm
jd and i was like i'm jd i was getting
us drinks and they said oh no she's in
the closet right now with jd they're
playing seven minutes in heaven
and i said whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
this sounds like seven minutes in hell
to me
so so then they come out of the closet
bingo bango next thing i know
they're dating oh okay so he stole your
girlfriend and you could you could hear
her in the closet she was like oh jd oh
jd between kisses she was like oh jd and
i was like i'm jd
i'm jd right and then and then she comes
out again i tell you she comes out and
she's like i'm with this jd oh so you
know what i chose
what was that what was that again i said
[ __ ] jd vance oh okay okay not not not
[ __ ] you jd no why what she did she did
[ __ ] him though right she did she did
she did [ __ ] him though right like is
that what you're saying
i agreed to come on i didn't want it i
didn't want to get trying
you know i really thought that i was
gonna be uh become that kid you know i
was gonna be i could have been a
contender you know like i thought i was
gonna be i had a real shot okay because
he said your name on stage i get it so
so let's talk about jd vance as the
candidate not as the guy who stole your
your girlfriend right um and you [ __ ]
your girlfriend let's talk about the guy
who won who appears to win the primary
of the republican last night um jd vance
he's got a lot of views um that seemed
to be kind of
i don't know anti-american almost to me
and even even to his opponent tim ryan
um who is the person who won the
democratic ticket tim ryan um is the
person who's gonna run as the democrat
so we have in the in the midterm
election you're gonna have jd vance the
guy who who stole and [ __ ] your
girlfriend and then tim ryan probably
the guy who appears more like a guy he
would steal
right and in [ __ ] your girlfriend um but
those two are going to compete in this
race what do you have to say about jd
vance you know him appearing to not be
as america first as maybe the the
fascist uh maga trump humping movement
like you're a part of
right
what tell us about that what
what i'm sorry what would you just call
me i i said you're part of the fascist
maga trump humping movement oh yeah yeah
the q and the q anon movement
yeah yeah i i wasn't misspeaking jfk
junior is coming back yeah right yeah
yeah yeah yeah
let's let's not get let's not get off
let's get on let's get okay what i will
say about jd vance okay he called
america a joke okay he said uh our
country's kind of a joke i'm sorry uh
our founding fathers didn't think that
it's like i mean get with it you know
it's like if you truly are a patriot
america is not a joke right america is
the city upon a hill right that shining
beacon of light right that place in
which other people come to us as they're
saving grace okay
okay so so you're saying you're saying
that
if you had a candidate that thought that
jd vance was the joke instead of
jd vance thinking the country was a joke
you might vote for them is that what
you're saying
you're saying that wait sorry say that
one more time if you had a candidate out
there in your because you live in ohio
you're a voter in ohio yeah i hope i
hope you're registered to vote if you
went and wrote in yourself as well i'm
in ohio yes okay and so if you're
registered in ohio wouldn't you want to
vote for a candidate that is against jd
vance saying that our country's a joke
and that he's kind of a joke and he
definitely would probably want to make
sure
to not make money like in china or
overseas it sounds a little hunter
bidenish doesn't it it does you know
where's jd's laptop am i right well i i
want to know i i would like to be
writing a sequel to his dumb book
did you read his book can you read i
mean i guess i should ask you that first
can you read hillbilly wannabe that's
what it is yeah right right well he is a
hillbilly wannabe for sure but but it
sounds like you would vote for a
candidate who was on the same page as
you about jd vance the guy who stole
your girlfriend you should you should
want to vote you won't you should want
to vote for someone from ohio who wants
to work for the american people who
doesn't just up and leave for his
hollywood elites right his leftist
friends right go be a correspondent on
cnn cnn wait wait wait wait do you mean
do you mean jd vance the guy that stole
your girlfriend was on on fake news as a
correspondent he was paid by fake news
yeah he was a
an
analyst
analyst oh i i see i see
you're not you're not it's analyst it's
analyst it's spelled like anal well
right right
anal
ist
analysis he's an analyst okay okay fair
enough
okay tony i'm not over here writing
dictionaries okay
i'm really reading them you know
that analyst he's an analyst with the
fake news network cnn apparently yeah so
you would vote for you would vote for a
guy who was opposed to this stuff then
is what you're saying
oh i would most definitely vote for a
guy that was totally against jd vance
that [ __ ]
girlfriend stealing wannabe hillbilly i
well i i don't blame you i don't blame
you that you would vote against jd vance
and make sure to keep ohio in ohio right
to make sure it's someone who is ohio
who is born in ohio raised in ohio four
ohioans who doesn't call america a joke
who doesn't call our country a joke
exactly that's who that's who the people
should be voting for you know i found a
video
of of a candidate and i believe this is
uh his name is tim ryan he's running on
the ticket too i i can't figure out from
this video if he's a democrat or
republican maybe you can tell me uh if
you'd vote for this candidate here um
let's play it here see if you'd vote for
this candidate people may not always
agree with my rhetoric but i think
unfortunately our country is kind of a
joke that's what i said events left ohio
for san francisco to make millions and
invest in companies that profit from
globalization and free trade he became a
celebrity cnn analyst and a big hit at
washington cocktail parties now vance
says he feels out of place in ohio and
he wants to represent you in the senate
what a joke
i'm tim ryan and i approve this message
so you think people may not know
do you think you would vote for tim ryan
over jd vance yeah i would vote if i
knew that tim ryan was running and i
didn't have to write myself in i would
have voted for tim ryan oh would you
look this is great this is great news
because i believe the news is i don't
think it's official yet but i believe
the news is that tim ryan if you are
registered in ohio you will be able to
go vote for him in november during the
midterm election jd well i'm gonna vote
for i mean you know clearly i only got
eight votes you know including mine but
wait wait you had eight people vote for
you
yeah eight
eight people including myself i mean one
one also my my mom and then my sister so
you know but eight people voted that's
pretty good that's pretty good votes on
the ballot that's but if you're telling
me that this guy tim ryan i don't know
who this guy is but if you're telling me
this guy is running in november oh [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah he's running he's running
he's a democrat he's a democrat running
in ohio he's on the democratic ticket so
so go vote go vote for yeah he's a he's
a democrat he's a democrat that's right
that's right and he's he's he's making
sure to be against uh jd vance being a
trader to ohio going to san francisco
making money off china and all the
elitist and then being an analyst as you
call it analyst on fake news cnn
yeah tony i feel like you're putting me
between a rock and a hard place right
now oh yeah you're telling me that this
guy's anti-jd which i'm anti-jd okay
right right you're you know all all the
points that i brought up during the
during this interview you know tim ryan
said exactly those same things it's
almost like we're on the same wavelength
i know and you're telling me that this
guy is going up against jd vance in
november yeah well q anon is a hypocrite
listen listen jd q anon is a hell of a
drug it's a hell of a drug and you
really
you really should maybe check out um you
know you know some things on the side of
facts and that might help you through
this process jd it really might help you
through this process i don't know i'm
feeling i'm feeling very confused right
now
um
i don't know i don't know what to
believe anymore well i tell you what
we're gonna take a break and i
appreciate you joining us jd please come
back
more during this election to give us
your insight into how you're feeling
about uh tim ryan running against your
enemy jd vance yeah um and i got a
special a special commercial for you so
don't forget to watch through the break
jd
um because there is a there is a special
trump fund out there for people who are
sad and broken like you there is and um
so everyone
out there yeah so jd thanks jd mandel
everyone thank you for joining us jd
again we'll bring you back
as long as it's uh relevant which
you may or may not be relevant thanks a
lot jd thanks for joining us
thank you thank you everyone stick
around we'll be right back after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw can't wait
another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
thanks for uh sticking with us
[Music]
from the interview of jd mandel i think
that's the first public interview
that jd mandela has done right here on
the tony michael's podcast an exclusive
interview
with jd mandel gabe sanchez thank you
thank you for getting us that interview
that was fantastic you got it yeah yeah
he was here did you did you catch the
did you catch it or were you no no i was
i was i was dealing i had called my
accountant i had some uh you know got to
do the whole taxes thing sure sure sure
yeah
you know it's it's after tax day right
yeah but you know there's an extension
oh okay okay okay so you know
yeah it sounds like what jd mandel had
to do with his election and i don't know
if you caught it but jd mendel wrote
himself in and the breaking news here on
the tony michael's podcast gabe is that
jd vance the guy who's running in the
ohio senate race the republican who
possibly looks like he won that
republican nomination yeah he actually
stole
jd mandel's high school girlfriend high
school sweetheart breaking right here on
these whoa
i'll tell you what game so they know
each other i tell you what gabe here's
what we'll do i'll cut that out you guys
go subscribe to the youtube channel and
gabe we will post it on the youtube
channel so you can re-watch it so
everyone go to youtube subscribe the
tony michaels podcast search and we will
put that interview
up on uh the tony michaels podcast on
youtube so go subscribe to the channel
again uh we we appreciate having
everyone here what a great what a great
what a great day we had a lot of
engagement here we had our trolls
engaging we had all of our our all of
our great fans engaging
um and we love having you guys here on
the show yeah um you know and i'm glad
i'm glad you were able to get that
interview for us i think it was helpful
to everybody i had to go through some
back channels to get him but i mean i'm
glad he showed up you know it was a bit
of a bit of an issue in terms of trying
to figure out how did you how did you
find jd mandel because i didn't i
thought i thought this person didn't
exist there's a lot of mandels in ohio i
always had to go through the white pages
and and call so wait you got out the
phone book or you went ahead
no i i well i i got i got a phone book
right uh i had a buddy ship me one from
ohio oh okay that's why it's been a few
days since we've been able to get this
exactly yeah yeah so basically the last
few days i've been literally calling
through you know combing through mandels
you'd be surprised again how many
mandels there are and they're all
actually unrelated which is weird oh
okay yeah i was like oh are you oh
mandel are you related to jd mandel and
someone's like oh [ __ ] no and i was like
oh mandela are you related to jd and
they're like oh no but i wish so you
know and it was like back and forth but
everyone finally you finally found the
right one i did yeah it was crazy well
that's good that's good i appreciate you
working hard to get us the news breaking
interviews
that we so desire in our audience so
desires here on the tony michaels
podcast again don't forget to go
subscribe to the youtube channel we will
post that jd mandel interview the the
exclusive interview exclusive interview
he also called it's funny
jd mandel that we just interviewed he
called jd vance
a cnn
analyst he he mispronounced the word i
think you mean an analyst oh right it's
analyst right right right i think he
well he was on cnn as an analyst why is
he an email right which is really
[ __ ] funny to me that
that jd vance won the nomination in ohio
as a trump pumpkin
trump pumping fool
and he was part of fake news right like
right yeah left is fake news right and
this guy this guy for anyone who doesn't
know anything about jd vance he did
write a book and they made a movie about
the book and the reason why the movie is
really hailed as a good movie because
there's damn good actors in it i've
never seen it but i've heard good things
for the acting right the acting is
really good in it now the story is
really i mean it's kind of a shitty
story because jd vance dumps all over
uh quote unquote his hillbilly culture
he's he's kind of a culture traitor as
it were he's like a wannabe yeah he and
and then he and then you know that's why
he was an elitist and he was against
trump and all this [ __ ] you know he's on
fake news cnn is as the trump person
call it yeah and then he talked to when
it when it suited his fancy he became uh
a trump supporter again and he loves
trump absolutely loves it yeah i mean
america's hitler
yeah yeah right so um jd vance is a
[ __ ] hypocrite and a dumb [ __ ] and
he's a bonehead
um and you know the nice part is about
ohio is that it's kind of a it's kind of
a purple state you know it's kind of a
swing state so a democrat can actually
you know run fairly center in that in
that state and tim ryan actually won the
primary
last night for the democratic senate
seat and guys we should be very excited
about tim ryan winning that seat and the
reason why is because
that commercial that i showed jd mandel
i don't know if you've seen it gabe but
that commercial
a person watching that commercial that
doesn't know much about politics would
have no clue if tim ryan is a democrat
or republican and i believe that is more
what the democratic party needs to do in
some of these states everyone wants to
know how to get rid of joe manchin and
how to get rid of kirsten cinema and how
to get a majority and how we get voting
rights it's to get people who believe in
that stuff
who truly vehemently believe in freedom
and liberty and the constitution like i
think tim ryan does elected in states so
that we have the majority so they can
actually vote on the agenda that the
majority of americans want regardless of
their party
regardless because i think there's going
to be a lot of non-democrats that vote
for tim ryan
a lot and i think there's going to be a
lot of [ __ ] trump supporters that
stay at home because jd vance is a
[ __ ] fraud he's a phony he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about trump supporters he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about that i mean if
he can easily switch between one and the
other to say he's you know he sees trump
as america's hitler and then quickly go
to kissing that ass
easily see
as someone who would would flip on their
constituents and do the exact opposite
of what they should like you can't trust
that guy
he can't he just can't be trusted right
like he does i mean not to say that he's
unlike any other sort of politician or
specifically republican politicians who
kind of you know do what's in their own
uh interest instead of the constituents
but
uh if he's so easy to go from one side
which is anti-trump to pro-trump within
a short span of time because it suits
him
then i don't know if you can trust him
right and no the one the one thing the
one ad and i cut a clip and i don't know
if i could find it this quickly but the
one ad that gets me the jd vance cut to
win this
to win this and to sway the trump voters
do you remember the ad where he's like
are you racist do you hate mexicans like
he said those words yeah yeah he said
those words
right yeah are you racist do you hate
mexicans like what the [ __ ] yeah i mean
like he he he overtly and outrightly use
the racism that is part of the fascist
manga movement i mean the response of
someone is like are you racist and
you're like no no do you hate mexicans
no of course not i love taco tuesday
right right like and then when you're
asked those questions it's obviously
specifically
formatted in a way where you're gonna be
like well no of course not no i i i'm
not a racist right like i don't hate
mexicans they they clean my house right
and i'm not saying that oh my god but
when i
get from everyone everyone calm down
everyone count them
i am mexican and i am putting out what
gave him i'm gonna click what jd van
says okay i'm gonna i'm gonna clip that
out and i'm gonna post that and
you you you are a big trouble i hope
sanchez
here's
can't
thing
i'm not saying it it's jd vance and
every other white person in ohio that's
like oh i'm not racist i don't hate
mexicans well you know i think some
excuse like oh i i can't be racist i
have a black friend it's the exact same
thing exactly well and i've had this
discussion with some of um my
family members who are trump supporters
about uh migrants coming over and work
migrant workers coming to this country
and taking jobs that possibly someone
wouldn't want and they yell and scream
about all the people who hire them and
they're here to take our jobs and blah
blah blah you know on and on and on with
you know they're lazy but they're here
to take our jobs right but but i always
ask them i always make sure to ask this
question how many how many foreign
migrants born
migrant workers work at mar-a-lago
and when i see that
oh
right
they asked for permits at mar-a-lago
every year to get migrant workers to
come here from foreign countries to come
here to work at mar-a-lago on work
permits um because it is probably can
you imagine trying to have to clean that
[ __ ] place have to clean up all the
dirty diapers everywhere and dirty
diapers and the orange goo on the wall
you know yeah
sorry for the people have to work there
and clean it up and i again i will say
this as someone who is mexican
[ __ ] trump
and [ __ ] jd vance yeah well uh [ __ ] jd
mandel too uh but what a great interview
that you captured first that was great i
can't wait to watch it again again
everyone gave just
well cut that up i'll i'll cut it up for
you i'll cut it up for you and we'll put
it up on the youtube channel yeah we'll
put it up on youtube channel for for
everyone to watch so go subscribe to the
youtube channel thanks for joining us
today we're running out of time here i
i'm so glad that jd vance came in there
at the end and it was perfect um
everyone uh make sure to follow us again
on youtube twitter and twitch um don't
forget tomorrow
tomorrow we're gonna have the bonehead
of the week poll on at tony michael's
pod but here's the thing everybody gabe
promised last week that we would have
the bonehead of the week poll on youtube
too i do so we're gonna find out so now
give gabe some slack here this is the
first week that we will do the bone end
of the week poll i gotta know i gotta
calculate right both polls now but i'm
doing it for everyone so they have
accessibility because i know not
everyone has twitter
right so you can participate in the in
the youtube poll right so so you'll be
able to vote on youtube and twitter this
week yeah for bone of the week don't
forget tomorrow afternoon evening
sometime when we discover who these
boneheads are because we used to do it
earlier in the week but now we have to
do it later in the week because there's
so many there's so many [ __ ] boats
so so we'll we'll figure out who the
three bonehead of the week contestants
are you guys go vote on youtube
or twitter so don't forget to subscribe
to youtube as well because you can vote
there
for bone of the week and then friday me
and gabe break down the bone of the week
in the second hour because gabe we do
this show two hours a day every single
week day monday through friday on
youtube twitter twitch and now on the
midas touch facebook page we broadcast
live we simulcast as it were to the
minus touch facebook page so right like
us there on um
on facebook and there's the link there
on facebook for everyone on facebook
there's a link there for the for the
years
with social medias yeah what's on
youtube subscribe right if you go to the
youtube link you'll be able to subscribe
and then participate in the
in the bonus of the week poll and
because you know what
at this show
on this show
your vote matters that's right that's
right we believe in democracy here even
if it's to clown these [ __ ]
also don't forget to go download on
apple spotify and google
every single episode and gabe some
special news we did this last week and i
think we're gonna continue to do it we
did a best of
show
on saturday that aired on youtube but we
also put that on the directories you
guys downloaded the hell out of it yeah
and you also we put bonehead of the week
the last couple weeks on the directories
all by itself and they downloaded the
[ __ ] out of that too so i think we're
gonna continue to do that so you guys if
you go to apple spotify or google you
get the tony michaels podcast
every single week
every single day of the week excuse me
seven days seven days a week
seven days a week
seven days a week you get the tony
michaels podcast every single day even
saturday and sunday saturday we'll have
the best of and then sunday sunday we
will clip out bonehead of the week just
for you so you don't miss it so you can
listen to just how we break down your
vote for both end of the week so don't
miss any of this
you're going to want to follow subscribe
follow like like smash that button
whatever whatever whatever back comment
share it whatever subscribe that's right
whatever it is supposed to say on the
tubes of you or the books of face are
the tweety tweets and trendy trends
are the tubes of you
let's do that and until tomorrow at noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking